this is Anna dharmas and I'm Chris Evans
and this is the wired autocomplete
interview
I'm Chris Evans
you're ready I can't wait is Chris Evans
beard real hey yes it is Believe It or
Not TGI budget just couldn't afford it
so I grew it myself it's Chris Evans
playing
it's not a gym
a genius typically didn't want bio it's
almost like Almost Famous how Almost
Famous isn't about a band it's about a
boy that loves a band so so Gene is more
than ancillary character but we're still
we're still tweaking it I would love to
though I want to see that it's Chris
Evans the killer Knives Out well well
you've seen the movie right right it's
so funny for a split second
came about years ago we can all say yes
he is nasty right well in ghosted we
actually get to like each other yeah
films we've done we're very adversarial
so for this movie we actually get to
kind of uh enjoy each other's company
well it's kind of like the like hate
like thing again yeah I think like as in
real life our relationship has evolved
here we finally get to to have a good
time together yeah not trying to kill
each other no not hating each other we
kiss yeah we do and the beer is real
is Chris Evans dad a dentist he is a
dentist which you know I need an
appointment I mean no longer he's
retired now but uh he was my dentist
growing up you know I had braces for a
long time
did God punish you with the braces trust
me the orthodontics yeah truly was
Christmas Evans
child actor you're not a professional
child actor I mean I do plays you know
that is being an actor I guess I mean I
imagine it more being like someone who's
actually on sets getting paid you don't
need to get paid to get an actor trust
me then I guess I was a little you know
kid actor yeah
is Anna De armas a Bond girl yeah about
girl I didn't have a romantic story with
bond which is usually what happens but I
am a Bond girl in no time to die and it
was one of the most wonderful
experiences I've ever had on set I love
that chicken character yeah stole the
movie
I'll do it
I thought you're gonna say the next Bond
girl
then you just said bye oh man I don't
know I think Paul McCall should be the
one almost
no martial arts I pretend
to know martial arts but no I mean I've
done some boxing or kickboxing but not
enough those are disciplines that
require a lot of
time and years of study and training and
all of that and I have not done that is
anode I miss whoops Cuban Cuban am I
cute one that was a really long thing
for the word Cuban
see sorry now I'm Cuban I was born in
Havana lived there until I was 18 years
old and then I moved to Madrid and I
still have my family there at my home
and I miss it every day I love my
country yeah does Andre armas have
tattoos see
I have two one little Moon here and one
little heart on my ankle is anode in
John Wick is she you haven't seen
jungwick the last one no it wasn't
raining
I'm not I'm not I'm not in John Wick I
wish because I do love this franchise so
much that's why I I was so excited and
so happy to be called for the follow-up
in ballerina it's a spin-off of John
Wick and it happens between John Wick
three and four and 2024 ballerina is
coming out and I'm so excited
how did Chris Evans get cast as Captain
America luck they wanted me to come in
and read and I was apprehensive it was a
back and forth it was a little bit of a
dance it was something I was really
nervous about doing and luckily they
were really good people in my corner who
kept nudging me Kevin feige and Robert
and a lot of great people kind of talked
me into it in his best decision in my
life uh I had to sneeze that whole
answer and it never came so I'm sorry if
it seemed like my head was somewhere
else going to cities now no it's gone
now how did Chris Evans and Scarlett
Johansson meet meet we met on the set of
uh perfect score we were both really
young you know I think after that movie
she went off to do Lost in Translation
and her whole world changed but yeah
we've known each other a really long
time and she's one of my dearest friends
we've done how many films I mean all the
Marvel movies we've done eight movies
together this I'm not liking this
yeah we're wrecking them up though what
are we trying to say we're getting there
okay I still have five more to go
how tall is Chris Evans
really
like really really be honest six feet
six one with the right shoes it can be
six feet yeah you're taller than that
thank you but really yeah really
okay
what is Ana de armas real name my name
is and has no explanation Anna Celia de
armas sounded great to me what is Ana de
armas in Blade Runner I play Joy and
she's a beautiful hologram from the
future what was Andre armas what was
that iris's first movie I just told you
oh it was a good name
um and it was it sounded great it was
una Rosa de Francia it was a cop
production with Cuba and Spain that was
my first film sounds a lot better than
Not Another Teen Movie what
car design of the armis drive Land Rover
because I need it I live in a
complicated areas so I need something
strong handle that would take me through
anything what color eyes does Andre
Hermes have yes yes they're Hazel
right no they're like yellow
yeah it's not the same as Hazel yellow
green oh yeah okay you look great
what is Chris Evans
okay what is Chris Evans job this next
one we could be better what was your job
a year ago well yeah it was I was
working on a movie go so that you should
all go see that's my job ghosted yeah
he's a creep what is it
is your sweater
sweater what
knives out well I assume but I can't
even like wrap my head around the
question it's like a Jeopardy what brand
what is Chris evans's sweater
um that's literally what that feels like
next one
dog breed I did that little swab once
and it came back boxer pit lab
Pomeranian what good but what is can you
have one word for it what breed is it
he's a mutt okay what is Christina's
favorite football team it's a no-brainer
Patriots all right
what is that this is a TV show that I
did in Spain
when I moved why did you leave it I
started this show when I was like 19 and
I was playing a school student for three
years and I just felt like oh it's time
to move on I'm not really doing much
more here I've done everything I've had
to do so it's time to go to go and I
asked him to kill me and they did why
why on a date she's so beautiful
yourself why well it's my hazel eyes the
Hazel yellow yeah is the Hazel the
Frijoles that's it
I had to skateboard for Scott Pilgrim
and you know I I got okay at it I guess
but you know I can stay on it I can stay
on I can snowboard really well that's
like my favorite thing to do in the
world and Chris Evans do flips yeah yeah
we grew up with the trampoline but I
grew up in the world where the
trampolines didn't have those Nets you
know what I mean I'm like come on you
got to get bounced off this thing and
break a bone at least once in your
childhood and Chris Evans speak another
language and I can fake it I can get by
if I you know listen hard enough if
someone's speaking Spanish I pick up
every like third word
Kendra you know that's not true
[Applause]
I know the beginning we were like uh uh
your opinions okay I'm like I think that
okay I'm like I feel that that's it
you're doing great uh
I can
but there's some horrible thing online I
had to do something I pressed for Marvel
where I was on stage and had to draw
something really quickly in front of
like 5 000 people and I drew this shield
and the first Circle was it's like I
drew it blindfolded with my left hand so
then I had to follow that and I flip my
thing it looks like a monkey Droid but I
actually can kind of draw don't don't
just not that day just not that day not
under pressure
is on a day armis left-handed no I'm not
left-handed I'm right-handed but I was
told when I was little I used to grab
like do more like left-hand stuff for
some reason my parents just got me used
to the right hand I think that's it wow
that's just wrong is Anna Day armis the
new Wonder Woman well I feel like Gal
Gadot is doing a great job so you know I
think
she should keep doing that yeah yeah is
Andrea Miss
yeah yeah I've been in a couple of
diamond commercials I was doing this
campaign for for diamonds for a little
bit but not anymore is Anna De armas
nominated for Alaska yes I was it called
a few weeks ago I was nominated for an
Oscar and it was pretty incredible and
very special especially because I loved
the project blonde was a very unique
movie and roll for me and it was
wonderful to be recognized for that I
was nominating for a kid's choice of
work
thank you
go see ghosted on uh apple plus did I
say that what you nailed it Apple TV
Plus